thank you
all right maybe I stand on in my I'll be
6'4
folks thank you Ralph for being here and
I want to particularly thank my good
friend Jim Clapper
truth the matter is
known in South Carolina I wouldn't be
standing we're not for Jim Clapton
she was one of my most consequential
leaders of South Carolina history in my
view
tough he's loyal is principle and uh and
he let me I'll have to tell you
something if he has your back you always
say goodbye and Jim is going to be back
here in your home with you and your
daughter
former member former mayor Steve
Benjamin couldn't be here today if you
all remember his team with your mayor
because he's traveling with his family
and it's great to have him here uh
part of our team but his mom and dad
I'm sorry
I once said everybody take a seat
there's no seats that said mine's so
stupid you know there were no seats
anyway
I also want to thank the leadership of
interface and Flex for hosting this you
know I'm going to talk about what we're
doing to invest in America and I mean
invest in America All America starting
here in South Carolina I'm going to talk
about the progress made in building the
economy from the little out and the
bottom up
not trickling down when you go from The
Middle on the bottom up everybody does
well the wealthy's still do very well
but that trickle-down economy not a
whole lot dropped in my Dad's kitchen
table growing up it's all part of an
economic vision for this country I came
to office to determine
some points of some my own team build
opportunity tournament to change the
economic direction of this country
to little trickle-down economics and get
rid of it for everyone
from the Wall Street Journal and
Financial Times called the program by
buildings I'm not sure they meant is a
compliment at the time
our plan is working
and one of the things I'm proud is that
is working everywhere not just in the
coast and big cities like previous
recoveries this time investment is
working and faculty is being built and
jobs being created happening in Rural
America the Heartland all across America
in communities that have been left out
and Hollow
this is what it looks like across the
country over 13 million new jobs since
I've been elected to office more jobs
than any president's ever created in the
first two years nearly 800 000
manufacturing jobs including 14
000 in this state alone just stayed
around
again that's more
than two years than it was created in
four years any other Administration
unemployment but below four percent in
the longest time in 50 years
inflation is less than half of what it
was a year ago and would continue to
work on you know I know we have more to
do bringing down inflation remains one
of the top priorities job satisfaction
nationally National because it's the 36
year high
share of working age Americans in the
workforce is as high as he's been in 30
years remember they used to say blind
spend all this money to keep people from
working
people are off the sidelines
20 years 20 years High
higher than every single one of my
predecessors and to pay for low-wage
workers
has grown the fastest Pace in two
decades and folks it's no accident
it's binomics in action
trickle-down economics has failed the
country for decades it means slashing
public investment from things that
helped America lead the world in
motivation you know we used to invest
two percent of our entire gross domestic
product
and research and development you know it
is now 0.7 we used to be ranked number
one in the world in research and
development nowhere ranked now number
nine
China's number eight a decade
America for godsend
we used to have the fastest effort the
best infrastructure in the world rated
number one
now we're rated number 13 in the world
infrastructure how can you have the best
economy in the world
and not have the best infrastructure in
the world
under my predecessor infrastructure week
became a punch line
every every every month anyway
on my watch would make an infrastructure
a decade headline a decade yesterday we
announced that since I took office we've
attracted a half a trillion dollars
497 billion dollars in private
investment in American manufacturing
both here and around the world
it's a story
the supply dominance in action instead
of exporting jobs to cheaper labor costs
what we did for decades we're creating
jobs here and exploring American product
not jobs
that's the store here in South Carolina
earlier we heard the leadership of end
phase say that 60 million dollars
they're investing here
well that's 1800 jobs across the country
you know of 600 permanent jobs right
here in South Carolina
all a direct result
of the so-called inflation reduction act
that we drove past well that's
specialization in the past with so much
money is coming in to make all this
happen
by the way hypothetically I want you to
hear about the deficit
the deficit 1.7 trillion dollars in two
years
[Music]
generates
generates growth
today's first commercialize the
component that converts solar energy
into electricity
and all that sold earnings it doesn't do
a whole lot of good if you can't do it
you can convert it in electricity
it's called a Divinity called solar
micro inverter
Jaws he used to go to Mexico in here
Romania and China are now coming home to
South Carolina
now in phase of partying with flex to
make these parts here in South Carolina
and today they're shipping their first
micro inverters made in America
the good news is 90 of these jobs
requiring television with no required
college degree
Flex is working with Midlands Midlands
Technical College in Columbia developed
training and Pathways from folks to get
these jobs since I took office we've
sent over 60 domestic manufacturing
amounts all across the Solar Supply
Chain one of the biggest is in Golden
Georgia
you may find it hard to believe but
that's Margarita's District
I'll be there for the groundbreaking
just today the department of energy
announced new incentives for companies
to bring solar power manufacturing back
to our Shores
we're in a real race China's ahead of us
this is another step in helping us need
to go 100
clean renewable energy electricity by
2035 by 2035 all electricity in America
is going to be generated by Clean Energy
it's a big deal
saving billions of times going into the
air solution
you see the same story in semiconductors
a small little Community Church the size
of the tip of your finger that
effectively everything in our lives on
your cell phone automobiles
refrigerators the most sophisticated
weapon system they need these and guess
what
American vented these chips we're the
ones that invented we sophisticate those
here we made them what they are
and over time we went from producing
nearly 40 of the world's chips down to
less than 10 percent
that's why we designed and I signed the
chips and science act all these names
don't mean much so you know what they
produce because I knew we had reclaimed
American leadership now
all over the country
semiconductor companies are invested a
record hundreds of billions of dollars
to bring chick production back home in
Ohio New York Arizona all across like
like outside Columbus Ohio Intel is
investing in a thousand acres outside of
Ohio
20 billion dollars 20 billion
it's going to take 7 000 people to build
the tubes they call them fats factories
and it's going to take 5 000 permanent
workers
there's Syracuse my crime is investing
up to 100 billion dollars over the next
20 years beginning now in Phoenix
Arizona
csmc is investing 40 billion dollars
including thousands of good paying jobs
as I said for example in Ohio 7 000 jobs
building the facility are going to
generate economic growth in an entire
region outside
because they're generating a very long
unique storage unique drugstores you
need a lot of things to maintain those
jobs
and we're also seeing 3 000 jobs there's
three thousands working in the past
you can make a hundred thousand dollars
a year that's the average salary
we'll be the college degree
because when you're granted
the middle class
a little class
it's a game changer who investing in
American agendas about bringing Supply
chains home
Clean Energy Future made in America
before the pandemic supply chain is one
of something most Americans thought
about
if I said you six years ago we're
worried about a supply chain you look at
me like huh
oh I would want you the same way
but today after delays and parts of
products everybody knows why Supply
chains matter
we know for too long China's dominate
the production of raw materials needed
for critical products that's why we're
building the lines into our friends all
across the world increasing our
production here at home to create
alternative sources for the minerals we
need our goal is to bring full battery
supply chain home
we create a battery built stretching
from Michigan to Georgia
in Chester County South Carolina
Albemarle is investing 1.5 billion
dollars
processed lithium for electric vehicle
batteries
that's not only crit 2 300 permanent
jobs that will lift up a whole Community
a whole Community restore some pride it
matters
the lithium will power components like
uh like we like it's got to be taking to
be made in Redwood mineral
excuse me regular materials mayor
Charles for the company's making the
largest investment in the state of the
history of the state
3.5 billion dollars to build a battery
materials manufacturing plant creating 1
500 jobs
it's another Community change
the game changer
and those materials will go into
batteries that'll be recycled by
companies like serving Solutions which
is investing 300 million dollars here in
Richland County creating another 300
permanent jobs
that's community of the community and
Community let's bring that change that's
on its way
the change in our community is going to
change the state it's going to change
the country
the general Library System
energy storage Technologies is investing
279 billion mid million dollars
it's a manufacturer of batteries to
store energy the power of the grid
hello
what do you think we have said if I came
when I was here trying to get the
nomination three years ago
and I told you a lot you know
I mean that we see this kind of
investment in South Carolina billions of
dollars
I think you would have been a little
skeptical
that's why I fought so hard for the
things I wanted to do
didn't get much help for the other team
Chase
since I signed the inflation reduction
Act and the chips in science acting law
companies have announced 11 billion
dollars in manufacturing and clean
energy investments just in South
Carolina
11 billion dollars
companies across the county are
somewhere across the country are
expanding factors that building new is
creating tens of problems
great job in America should be a good
job including free and fair choice to
join a union
technology will be made stronger my
collective bargaining relationships
that's up to the side it's not just
it's not just Manufacturing
the bipartisan infrastructure law we've
already announced over 35
000 projects all across America like the
prince French Bridge which is a billion
dollar operation over the Ohio River
from Ohio to Kentucky
today in New York for investing a record
billion dollars
built 100 years ago
it's falling apart to be able to go
through 100 miles an hour instead of 30
miles
over Union County South Carolina we're
building six Bridges critical to moving
people and goods across the street each
Bridge
is over 60 years old great body
restrictions that cause detours
congestion and Supply chains the oldest
one
is where South Carolina 49 crosses the
tiger River
the biggest one right here in Columbia
Now function Junction
we all know
how many years
[Applause]
now thanks to Jim collaborate a helpful
infrastructure law it's finally going to
get fixed
I get fixed
we're moving every single blood type in
America more than more than a hundred
thousand lead service lines go into
homes here in South Carolina
the risk to everyone's Health including
children so it's time to get them
removed and replaced we're building
we're helping Chris and school district
one here in Columbia purchase 16 new
electric buses because guess what the
district
y'all remember during the pandemic that
thousands of people in this state didn't
have a connection to high-speed internet
wherever in their business or their home
everybody now talks about
we're going to close that digital divide
not to buy between those who have
reliable internet connection those who
don't
South Carolina is receiving
one billion dollars
South Carolina
it doesn't have reliable high-speed
internet
thanks to Jim clyburn's affordable
connectivity program fancy name and it's
real
they're not saying that 359
000 South Korean families are already
saving thirty dollars a month
look we're doing this experience all
over the country
you see exactly where where the money's
going whether you're affected in your
community here are going to
invest.gov click on to invest.gov put in
your location I'll tell you what's
happening in your community
you all see projects with the Marine
communities all across America
look implementing this legislation
all those members of Congress are voted
against it suddenly realize how great it
is
and they're bragging about it and my
mother would say God love them
I want to thank Senator grant for voting
for the five Force intersection
and it ships inside
I wish you'd voted for the rest
every Republican member of the Congress
voted against the inspection reduction
of everyone every Republican member of
the House
in this statement information
you know and then after that effort
failed Republican study committee
includes only three quarters of the
House Republicans just released the plan
go out trying to refuel it all again
it's kind of incredible
not as billions of dollars and thousands
of jobs are coming to the United States
still unusual
distinguished center from the state of
Alabama former coaching University
is now failing capacity
great to see Alabama receive critical
funds the Boost ongoing Broadband
efforts
and it's great
that's all right
I'm one of those guys
folks I'm very serious now when I'm
raining when I got elected when I
propose these pieces of legislation I
made a commitment and I've been present
for all Americans in terms of their
election officials
America
I kept my promise in fact someone else
has to say that all as I've signed or do
more to help red America
that's okay with me we're all Americans
and my view is
wherever the need is most that's the
place we should be helping and that's
what we're doing
because the way I look at it the
progress we're making is good for all of
them all of them let me close with this
when I came to office we had a
fundamental decision
would we continue down the triple down
economic path the policy just failed us
time of the year
grew inequality saw a job shipped
overseas towns hollowed out
when I ran I promised me to not continue
down the tripod
here's the simple truth about trickle
down economics
it represented a movement and we walked
away from how this country was built
Dynamics is just another way of saying
restoring the American community
Lord should be able to get a good job no
matter where they live
apartment small towns in every part of
the country
to raise their kids
a good paycheck to keep their Roots
where they grew up that's the American
way my dad used to have an expression
he said Julia Johnson a lot a lot more
in the paycheck
special dignity
it's my respect it's convenient to look
your kidney and I say honey it's going
to be okay and me
that's five numbers
it's Ruden will always work best for
this country investing in America
when you invest in our people
when you strengthen the middle class
we see stronger economic growth that
benefits everybody
long said it's never been a good bet to
bet against America
and I can honestly say it's never been
I've never been more optimistic about
America's future you just have to
remember who we are from God with you
United States of America there is
nothing beyond our capacity if we work
together so let's continue to work
together God bless you all and may God
protect us
[Music]
[Applause]